were you guys ever actually ever able to
make any money from that whole situation
yeah yeah I mean I own the I own the
master to the song okay I didn't write
it so I don't own the publishing but I I
so you own the recording so anytime
anybody used the song
you get paid and then also does Arc get
paid for the PO the writing how does
that work can't talk about that oh you
can't talk about that okay so that's
nice though that you at least made a
little bit of money from it and you
still are you still getting paid to the
for sometimes people use it and yeah
sometimes nice I mean I like have a lot
of other stuff going on now luckily that
it's not my you know main source of
Revenue but like the way that it works
in the entertainment industry is like
when you're underage the way it's
supposed to work at least is like if
you're an underage person in the
industry you get a Coogan account set up
so when you turn 18 20 of everything
you've made it's opened up to you and
only you um which my parents would have
never like touched that